[Music]
who can set your throat out
stab you with a hook
who can fill your mouth with bees and
bring you to your knees the candyman
yes the candyman can
well now that i've lost all my viewers
it's time to talk about candymandy
[Music]
no not that one i'm talking about nia
decosta's 2021 take on the 1992 clyde
barker bernard rose film of the same
name in this video we'll be breaking it
all down comparing it to the original
and taking a deep dive into its ending
so grab my hook hand and make sure to
like and subscribe seriously only 10 of
you are subscribed because here we go
the first thing you'll notice is that
all those fancy logos before the movie
starts are shown backwards as if viewing
a reflection in the mirror mirrors play
a large role in both films both
figuratively and literally amir is what
original candyman killer played by tony
todd used to climb through the cabrini
green apartments to murder his victims
viewers are also tied to the candyman
folktale as protagonist anthony mccoy
states the legend is
if you say his name five times while
looking in the mirror
he appears in the reflection
and kills you in the new version mirrors
and reflections are how we the viewers
see many of the kills only through the
reflection can we see candyman himself
in the terrifying teenage bathroom kill
scene which i'll get to in a bit instead
of showing all the girls brutally killed
we only see a brief portion of the
murders through this small makeup mirror
yet we hear all the brutality going on
letting the mind piece together the rest
i personally found this more terrifying
than just showing everything straight up
the film just like a mirror offers a
reflection on society today on a deeper
level what is the film trying to say
about race class and society what if
anything has changed since the candyman
of 1992 as xander berkeley's character
says in the original about urban folk
tales they are the unself-conscious
reflection of the fears of urban society
the film starts on a young boy named
william burke in 1977's cabrini green
projects in chicago he's tasked with
doing laundry at this super creepy
laundromat and it's kind of ironic since
when we see adult william burke he runs
his own laundromat business it's also
ironic that a laundry machine which runs
on cycles reflects the cycle of candyman
itself i'll get to that and how burke is
tied to candyman in a bit as a child
burke encountered candyman or should i
say sherman fields as we'll find out
later candyman isn't a man or one person
he's as burke says the whole damn hive
candyman ain't that he
candyman is the whole damn hive sherman
was an odd fellow who handed out candy
to local children but when razor blades
started showing up in kids candy guess
who they blamed when cops found him they
shot him like an animal on site no trial
no justice nothing and his innocence was
proven weeks after his death when razor
blades kept showing up in kids candies
it's here that the urban legend of
candyman arose from the ashes once again
in the original we get a different
candyman origin story about a man named
daniel robitaille who was lynched and
killed after having an affair with the
daughter of a prominent wealthy white
man candyman isn't one person it's many
his survival is solely based on the
stories we give it thus we'll see many
candymans in this movie a hive as burke
called it the hive and bee symbolism
harkens back to how the original
candyman was smeared with honey and
attacked by hundreds of bees as producer
writer jordan peel says what candy man
wants more than anything is to be
eternal much like the candy ghost his
ambition lies in becoming eternal and he
achieves this through being ingrained in
the psyche of those who believe in him
and blood yes sweet sweet blood i am the
writing on the wall
the whisper in the classroom
without these things i am nothing
so now i must shed innocent blood after
burke's encounter with candyman we fast
forward 42 years to 2019 our protagonist
anthony mccoy is a struggling artist who
lives with his more affluent girlfriend
brianna and they just happen to live in
a new apartment right where cabrini
green used to be you see all that
remains of cabrini today are these
abandoned dilapidated two-story houses
the high-rises we saw in the original
were torn down in the 90s with the last
one coming down in 2011. it's a cycle of
gentrification white man forces black
people into the projects white man takes
them out and the cycle repeats anthony
is looking for inspiration for a new art
exhibit after he's told his work just
isn't cutting it by curator clive
privler i'm wondering if clive is named
after candyman creator clive barker so
when anthony hears about the story of
helen lyle the protagonist in the
original candyman he travels to the
abandoned cabrini green to check it out
there he takes photos just like helen
did he's also stung by a bee a beast in
which over the course of the film slowly
takes over his body turning his skin
into this gruesome honeycomb formation
one could also assume that this image of
the ants taking away the dead bees
symbolizes the candyman story the dead
bee is candyman and the ants the people
who keep his legend alive anthony pays
close attention to this church where
much of the end of the film takes place
it's fitting since in the original
candyman often uses a lot of christian
wording referring to his followers as
his congregation tonight our
congregation shall witness a new
miracle it's here in the third act that
candyman will once again be resurrected
through the body of anthony mccoy but
we'll get to that in a bit anthony is
startled when he finds a now adult
william burke on the cabrini grounds and
this guy knows a lot about candyman he
recites to anthony the story of him and
candyman as a child and anthony becomes
inspired using this inspiration to show
off some brand new paintings at his art
exhibit a showing which doesn't go over
well with clive and chicago art critic
finley stevens both panning his work the
name of his exhibit is say my name
conjuring images of the black lives
matter slogan say their names used to
remember those black men and women who
died at the hands of police brutality
candyman like those who lost their lives
can only be remembered if we say their
name and for candyman it's quite literal
remember you have to say his name five
times for him to appear which is exactly
what clive's girlfriend does when the
exhibit is over and she wants to get
freaky with clive i've heard of women
wanting their guts rearranged before but
not like this they're attacked by
candyman and it is bloody as hell
anthony sees the news of the murder but
is more interested in his name being
blasted on the tv than the murders
themselves it's here we really start to
see a descent into madness as his body
and mind succumb to candyman's power as
more murders occur the more infamous he
and candyman become the two have a sort
of symbiotic relationship at the same
time anthony's girlfriend is bombarded
with job offers in the art curation
space but soon finds out it's not really
because of her ability people are just
wanting to use her to gain access to
anthony who has now become a big draw
for these galleries the man whose
exhibit resulted in the deaths of a
renowned curator would draw a large
crowd we also get a glimpse at brianna's
backstory her father was a tortured
artist whose work led him to commit
suicide a suicide she witnessed
firsthand as he threw himself off a
building that's why she locks away all
his artwork in his storage locker and
refuses to talk about him with her
brother troy it's ironic then that she
ends up dating a tortured artist who
also descends into madness anthony does
more research into helen lyle uncovering
her audio tapes at the university of
chicago where she was a grad student he
learns that the candyman folktale was
created as a means of self-preservation
for the cabrini green community a way
for them to consolidate the horrors of
everyday life into a mythical figure an
entire community starts attributing the
daily horrors of their lives to a
mythical figure in the elevator filled
with reflective mirrors of course
anthony is shown as being the reflection
of candyman hinting at him becoming the
next iteration he's surprised when he's
asked to meet that art critic who panned
his work she wants to do a story on him
now that he's become a known name she
wants to use and discard him for her own
game just like the projects were used
and then discarded he tells her if she
wants to know the real story behind
candyman she should say his name five
times in the mirror which she does but
when she goes off to the bathroom
anthony is spooked off when he sees a
reflection of candyman again and we get
this cool death scene where the critic
is killed instead of showing it up close
and personal it's shot in an extreme
wide from outside the apartment we see
not hear her being brutally killed as
people in neighboring apartments go
about their lives oblivious to the
horror beside them i can't help but
think this is a commentary on the black
experience a lot of pain and suffering
happening right before our eyes being
ignored as we go about our lives brianna
confronts anthony who at this point has
gone off the deep end telling her that
candyman is real she can't stand that
he's turning into the thing that's
pained her the most her father meanwhile
we get a short segment where a teenage
girl who visited anthony's art exhibit
decides to try out the candyman game
with her friends as you can expect this
does not go over well this is also where
we get our first glimpse of candyman
floating something that is only seen
twice in this movie but multiple times
in the original the words say my name
are written in blood on the bathroom
wall the same name of anthony's art
exhibit which is important because it
leads the cops to believe anthony was
responsible and now that two critics of
his are found dead as well it's not
looking good for him while getting his
now absolutely grotesque be stung hand
examined at the hospital he learns he
was born in that very hospital near
cabrini green this is weird because his
mother told him he was born on the south
side so he goes and confronts his mother
who is none other than anne-marie mccoy
played by vanessa williams a character
from the original and i gotta say damn
vanessa has been 30 years and it looks
like you haven't even aged 10. she tells
anthony that he was the baby boy
captured by candyman way back in 1992
and saved by helen lyle candyman's
purpose for him to make candyman even
more renowned was to have him burn in
this giant fire a fire which helen ends
up saving him from from that day forward
anne-marie vowed never to say candyman's
name again and fabricated anthony's past
in order to protect him rihanna tracks
down william burke in the hopes he might
know anthony's whereabouts but in the
process ends up getting captured by him
burke has also captured anthony who at
this point is in some sort of fugue-like
state he doesn't even feel it when burke
saws off his arm and inserts a hook in
his place you see burke is wanting to
recreate anthony in candyman's image but
why would he want to bring back
something that gave him so much trauma
as a child my interpretation is that he
wanted to save the last remaining part
of cabrini green in an effort to protect
it from the viciousness of the outside
world if brianna is to bear witness to
candyman's return and tell the world
that he's real no one would possibly
want to move in there as burke says of
the gentrifying white upper class they
tore down our homes so they could move
back in we need candyman it all harkens
back to what helen lyles said in the
original that his legend was used as a
sort of excuse for the daily horrors of
their lives or is committed to them by
police crime and society itself in this
way candyman is two contradictory things
at the same time killer and protector
brianna manages to escape her confines
and in her escape kills burke ironically
with a shard of glass from a mirror but
here is where things get really twisted
anthony arrives and collapses in her
arms as a squad of police cars arrive
the cops shoot anthony on site even
though he was of no danger to them it's
basically exactly what happened to
sherman at the beginning of this tale
brienne is put in the back of a squad
car where one of the policemen tells her
that this can go two ways one she
testifies that anthony lunged at one of
the cops and the shooting was justified
or two she goes down as an accomplice
it's just another form of how corrupt
this police force is and briana says
she'll agree to whatever he says as long
as she can use his rear view mirror
which she does to summon candyman and
here is where it gets really interesting
candyman appears in the form of anthony
killing all the cops who also happen to
be white he moves around the car as we
see the reflection of previous candyman
it's evident that these candymen are the
haunting reminder of black men
wrongfully killed in racially motivated
murders one of the cops runs and
candyman goes after him brianna watches
as the cop is killed and a swarm of bees
around candyman's face part to reveal
the original candyman underneath who
says the line tell everybody he spares
briana because candyman can't exist
without people believing in him if she
survives she can tell his story and
strike fear in a new generation i doubt
anyone will be wanting to move into
cabrini green anytime soon and in this
way burke gets what he wanted all along
this ending also leaves open the
potential for sequels since candyman
will always be around so long as we
remember him that's my take on 2021's
candyman but i want to know what you
thought about the movie in the comments
below thanks for watching and be sure to
like and subscribe i'm always coming out
with new content and for more bad takes
you can always follow me on twitter and
instagram at think story yt until next
time remember
daddy loves you very much